So, for any given function when we're considering x to be the input and y to be
the output, there's never going to be more than one value of y for any value of
x that we look at. Now, since I told you that these were some examples of
functions, why don't we take a look at each of them and see how this concept
applies. So first, you have the line y equals negative 2x plus 5, which I've
drawn for you down here. And we can see that as we move across the horizontal
axis, we're never going to be able to move up to more than one y value or down
depending on your position. Now, for this parabola. Once again, even though this
isn't a straight line, if we move horizontally across the graph, we'll never
encounter more than one vertical coordinate for a given horizontal coordinate. Y
equals negative 5 is just a horizontal line. And we can see, once again, the
same concept applying.